okay yes okay yes okay once again yawn
you are the tournament director so you
will be choosing the games am i choosing
games from our yes these members of our
team so the one tab will be for the
games and the other tab will be well
where we will be choosing the games okay
okay here we are back okay we're back I
had to do a full restart and hopefully
now it's it's better so if anyone could
just inform us is it is the audio and
video okay and we were gonna try and try
and go smoothly from now on so the idea
was to frighten you a little bit yes
that was that was the idea but I was
also pretty frightened so yeah okay
obviously we have the first game in
front of us so Eddy a member of our team
yeah a member of our team versus a
member of the obviously the the crest
crest chess Flavia okay and we're doing
better on time so it could be it could
be good stream complete what I think we
shouldn't pay attention to I guess I
don't know yeah if it will persist we're
gonna we're gonna switch to a different
Internet yeah if there are any okay yeah
no it's good
like if there are any issues yeah we're
still gonna try and fix them but
hopefully hopefully now yeah sorry about
that
definitely sorry about that I have no
idea what's happening okay so what do we
have here well we do have a person with
white pieces yeah her with an ice queen
trade offer and that's a pawn and it was
an intentional pawn sandbox for activity
okay Wow
that's it and now the grandma has the
grandma I'm sure okay should I say yeah
yes you could say the moves Ruchi for
Raja for seems interesting yeah you can
say the moves
the queen is protected yeah but the Ruby
G for force is a Queen trade then you're
down upon no no you're not oh he just
recaptured okay have much more active
pieces I would say but I don't see like
any yeah I mean a queen g6 with a
doubling of the pawns could have also
been I think but okay I think this is
now equal and it's gonna be tough for
our for our good friend Eddie yeah
nevertheless we are cheering for him ya
know the link works definitely since
I've tried it the link myself
moments ago yeah okay it seems that it
will be down to who is better yeah it
always comes down to bullet oh nice move
997 with rookie 7 that's a pond that's a
healthy pond with me now yeah now it's
bullet
now it's bullet I think with age 4 and
[Music]
starting to expand on the kingside white
is looking pretty good yeah they're 93
with tempo is it easy to say when oh
okay another pawn yeah so what's what's
happening here check check he exchanges
and goes into a routine game he doesn't
want to he
could have even capture on a 7 yeah but
it's still too early he doesn't want to
go into a rock n game
okay now hmm probably should have gone
for it check again
I think I would even capture on d4 and
yeah I think he just has to be really
quick here with the king of one she is
pretty
he's trying to he's trying to win he's
not trying to be quick okay capture on
okay oh this is so intense
check and pull those pawns yeah you
should start pushing the boxes yeah oh
okay okay I still think he will be able
to no he won't
yeah I mean he does have ten seconds
more so yeah but it's enough for a for a
grandmaster I would say see never know
grabs grabs yeah oh and it's a draw okay
okay first draw for our team epic stuff
okay so okay so just go here click and
now just click on any of them oh okay so
on points and now you're see who's
playing okay let's select the first one
okay
just open in a new tab and let's let's
follow our good friend yellow lights
yeah oh it's okay
against the the checkmate Channel
everybody has a channel yes that's
having a channel is the new black okay
it seems that this is a very very
interesting place where there are a lot
of threats on both sides of the board
why distracting threatening 97 black is
threatening the capture on c3 so what I
would say white is better white is
better but we'll see what our friend
yellow white sword okay whoa okay
decides not to capture not to complicate
I guess Bishop g7 could be the best move
here is that's true you can just click
your scroll wheel to open a new tab you
don't have to go right click yeah thank
you for that will save us many clicks
yes I gotta admit I am a mobile
developer not a web developers okay so
I'm not too embarrassed okay that I
didn't know that so yeah thanks for the
tip where's the dog the dog is sleeping
as usual even when you don't see the dog
in the video meadow is always behind
either behind me or behind anyone
sitting in in this chair is that a piece
I think it is very nice yellow else
very nice capture the piece on d4 and
now let's protect it somehow well any
move will do
26 okay gotta be careful I gotta say the
dynamic is very different where we are I
am kind of used to having those two plus
so you know okay
streams where ah so weak or very fast
yeah and here it's much much slower
yeah the opening joke yeah that's that
that's the the greatest one we've heard
so far I don't think we had a better
better to date okay so still protecting
the pawn okay oh and that's a resign
good on yellow lights okay how are we
doing we are in third place we're in
third place okay Moroccan and chess nerd
okay yeah you just hover over it okay I
think it just finished oh no it didn't
okay
you use the the wheel this time huh yes
I did and it worked okay are ya the
crest chess club are incredibly strong
there I think their weakest player is
like 2500 so yeah we're not gonna go
into that too much there are 70
something points ahead well okay that's
that just sounds wrong but you know if
everyone is Burger King it is possible
nice capture here okay there so I think
I think Moroccan Chester has to be
careful for the pawns yeah although an
actor berserk so he might be able to do
it if that no that's that that's very
yeah that was a pre move he shouldn't
have pre moved
yeah indeed
we just closed yes we should close that
okay and this yes okay what's the name
of the team it's a lot of steam and a
link to it is in the description below
if you if you wish to join our our epic
team oh nice
I mean is this game still going on
Wow he might know that one is checkmated
yeah if only he didn't have any pawns
oh very nice
yeah a nice effort but that one pre-move
call on the game okay so 212 points for
the crest book okay there is some battle
between okay it's gonna be interesting
okay let's see let's see let's see okay
a lot of people on it wonderful
yeah and goo dog has o jumped into okay
let's see let's see some games mister
tournament director okay love lives
Shevchenko is playing against a top
player okay let's see how he does
good luck okay that's a good point yeah
that is a good point
hmm this point is gonna be okay and very
annoying yeah it's an annoying pawn on
this that Queen has to go everything has
to go yeah yeah he heard me he heard me
and now Bishop a5 create as many pieces
as you can and get those he heard me it
seems that he is watching a lot of your
videos okay gotta be careful yeah
captures captures captures captures yes
I need to not just the bishop capture
everything get the rook in and and we're
good here that's it
just follow the capture oh yeah oh okay
he decided to you know yeah look it's
deep
okay and then Queen g5 yeah you have to
do it
Queen g5 yeah after drew it's a very old
saying he who captures wins okay it's
still looking good yeah it's not for
white for what is looking good but it's
not the worst for black no it's not he's
hanging in there
he's half the time but you know it could
happen yeah
just one wrong pre moving then that's it
no Icarus we cannot tell the English
opening joke again it would be it would
be too much of just media means okay
yeah that means chests in Turkish that's
so drunk yeah I don't know how you
pronounce it okay I hope I didn't
butcher butcher it so much I think this
is game yeah but will he resign yes he
will okay let's see how how our team is
doing okay still not that bad okay
pewter in international master from
Poland
whoa okay yeah okay you overseas you
over scrolled it I misuse the oh he's
against Vova Vova is a dangerous player
in our tournaments well he preserved
into ah oh that's dangerous against Vova
Vova is a much stronger than your
average chess player again yeah because
he's always among the top ten whenever
we have an arena so but I would say that
pewter is a true warrior yes everything
he is but look at those bishops brothers
they are nasty beasts okay
not anymore yeah and coins you know okay
a four no okay it's gonna be king each
one after this yeah he doesn't want to
play f4 with 95 oh maybe not okay that's
a piece before any okay night here
visual captures and
till I would play that too forced in
exchange
yeah I'm rookie to have f4 okay okay but
still it would check to capture on e3
okay
we'll see
okay before now captures captures and
now it comes with an attack on the Queen
Queen that to eat you and b3 yeah and
any five at some point sure it's a very
nice queen F to move she's down so a
little time but he is confident in his
endgame skills okay huh okay yeah Bishop
before is the play
a rookie one yeah and then Knight
capture some b2 but it doesn't really
matter
Queen g3 okay
yeah but he why this should happen okay
OBS reconnected is it over
okay are we back on uh I have no idea
yeah for some reason OBS started yeah
everything is up to date everything
should be properly working and yet we do
have some issues for some reason let's
just turn off everything we don't need
yeah yeah I mean antivirus could be
causing problems you know there was some
viruses or yeah escape the world yeah I
think we're back that's the important
thing
yes still going storm has 14 thank you
everyone thank you for for still being
here with all the all the internet
issues
I think I think kill the pewter will win
this yeah he has to capture that there's
no way around that
and now what night f1 h5 and rook to
mate
shush ff7 will come to check here
there's no escape I mean white is of
course much better but with 12 seconds
we're gonna see how tough of a warrior
kill the pewter is that's beautiful I
don't know I don't know he's going for
mate I like it
he's going for mate with us yes f6 rook
c8 yes King has to help it's very very
difficult
King gauge 5 to g6 to f6 ok
engage five to g6 no here and now it's
he's gonna force a few checks and now
mate you ok you could have gone to 7 so
yeah it's very difficult to play Oh
unfortunately the lack of time it was
incredibly strong but the berserk was
too much to handle
ok Peter is still the best yeah but we
have to check a lot of games ok Oh
another Eddy game and then we're gonna
check some other players as well sure
sure
we should check as many as possible I
agree do we have any GM's I don't think
so well do not I don't think so not yet
but you know anything can happen it's a
2-hour tournament you never know you
know ali reza might be bored
he might we'll see Eddie just just join
just won the games ok rest Eddie Eddie
massacred his opponent very nice even
the meter of ok grabbing a lot of points
for the team
TM even Dimitra TM whatever TM means
unfortunately I mean I heard it like a
hundred times but still good to chess
players so let's make this game
interesting so they stopped playing ok
that's a loss for us yeah ok sorry yeah
it's good I'm gonna put up in the joke
too good of a joke
okay so yeah when we join the game
already
okay mister saw rocks from Italy what is
mr. so rocks up to was a good position
good position for black but also that
c-pawn is very nice yeah for a person
that is born in 1995 he does have a good
rating but also Arkady who apparently is
born in 2005 okay that is if that's our
rating yeah okay if that is the year of
birth that is very nice 2005 what is
that that's like 15 yeah 15 14 15 yeah
okay okay what were you doing with your
15 me I don't know thinking about stuff
yeah maybe maybe some beer
you know philosophical yeah okay so
sorex
is some phones down and has okay but
it's no not the best position not the
best but still it's a bishop that c5
phone is strong if the King can get the
b5 maybe something can happen
I would totally a poor maybe further and
try to wear how would you push it the
apron
yeah a4 a5 and then try to do something
on the B file with rook yeah he's going
up with the king that's the stuff and
the bishop is very strong yeah defending
the pawn yeah from bishop without it was
game King c4 yes beautiful
and now route 66 no yeah okay okay no no
please b5 no uh he wants to create a
blockade if efore then f4 obviously I
don't think so it's I think Bishop g5 is
the idea and but I would exchange the
and then it's an easy capture on e4 yeah
white all of a sudden I think I got into
a better position that he was then he
was yeah that's a that's a good save and
now yes
okay okay black can't really enter the
position he can walk the bishop in with
a four but then it's just useless
useless three two one for black and he
will do it
so he says okay I'm not interested in
being better yeah that's what they
always say sex or know he's gonna
Riemann over the bishop to where 2 C 3 C
3 C 3 control tonight no oh no no yeah
great
ok so cannot capture on e5 because night
of 3 no he can yeah no he can no he
can't he won first his pawn that track
he wants to go he wants to go to f5 King
get 5 now wow loses the rook no but
these seven and d8 Wow nice ok that's
how we play Bishop against Knight that
is ladies and gentlemen that's a free
roof almost but the queening square is
guarded by the bishop so it it's all
good
but rookie 7 and he cannot go anywhere
white cannot go anywhere with you yes he
just pushes the pawn oh nice and then he
has king of six check before recapturing
the rope
you know where rook will capture and
then you capture with them no check and
then okay yeah look at six check that's
the stuff thumbs up for their socks now
check now okay that's beautiful
very glad that was good stuff mr.
Horrocks and he even gives it up he
doesn't want to be flagged yeah he's
gonna pick that pawn up as well and then
push the F pawn Wow very nice that
desert I hope you are all applauding the
good sir Sora academic clap yeah we move
on okay later
okay let's see shut up shut up he is
playing against pvz 1971 okay
everybody's putting their young births
there your birth maybe it's their
favorite year like you know my Bobby
Fischer in the candidates maybe yeah
could be could be which is the French
opening joke I know I'm wondering as
well yeah it's I I don't think we've
heard this one yes good stuff so rocks
okay so slim jim has a point
we should show maybe somebody with less
points and then give advice Thank You
Marcus hi hi Nolan for your for your
contribution sir but the question is
should we give good advice or bad advice
can you give bad advice
Oh in-betweener with an in-betweener oh
oh
Bishop's III very dangerous yeah cannot
even invade Shattuck had a nice idea but
who he is he had an even better one
yeah but III coming oh it's pretty much
over now
yeah I think this time too yeah it's
very it's better to resign let's rook
captures yeah that's a resign a better
to resign than to drag this on and maybe
just try yeah if you resign you can grab
more points but you know if you're if
you're one of those people that never
resigns I respect that I very rarely
resign myself but logically in all sense
to resign you want yeah so maybe you get
a lighter opponent next let's check out
the person with Antonio 94 Oh
Thank You Curt Morgan for your
contribution thank you sir
okay nothing is happening okay no oh we
saw already a game bye
of chenko but okay let's that's a good
choice but I cannot they're not playing
but the second to last is playing its
again yeah it's very it when you wake
it's quick it's definitely quick okay
Russ finger Russ finger plane over
against a very strong opponent yeah
freedom master a berserk and freedom
master that's a dangerous species
Stephen Rojas oh you have to go 95 yeah
you have to
I was with Bishop it's not bad it's not
bad okay you have 97 the other night of
course and rookie AIDS
yeah the roof it has to come have six I
mean it is a very maybe would have
played a six aha just to before yes dude
yeah 95 and 94 look how really annoying
I would go f6 definitely it's just just
a good move to get my queen away from
there
but where hey that's that's the question
he's gonna win b7 now
yeah Queen b7 okay need to move the
Queen out of the seven Knight of 6 he's
gonna do it like that
and he trades okay
no he doesn't if six F has to be played
not Ruki eight f6 could be dangerous now
because Queen e6 okay
it's fair also making some room for King
King g7 and it's gonna be difficult to
defend that f6 pawn
unless you push f5 but you know so his
idea was just to get out of this pin
yeah f5 if 95 you don't have a really
good response yeah I know not have six
to ninety six eight eight six okay it's
just move the Knight to h3 and then you
can play on Queen d7 and just continue
okay
what will
we'll see what's happening are the point
is you cannot really capture because of
the weakness oh he was the captures and
nice chicks win the Queen it's it's a
good stuff
queen of five yeah although there might
be some ideas with rook captures on d5
later and then I have four check winning
the Queen if that g3 tour never moves
which is very unlikely let's see if
night Eve okay maybe eight six or it's
just a just a weird position yes and
then Knight e5 to to kick the Queen away
yeah but Queen could capture on a queen
can capture yeah that's not good but
okay
I mean rogue block spawn for starters
maybe no okay uh he wants to capture on
g3 yeah he wanted to capture and g3 so
white cannot recapture with the pawn and
now now you you have June file maybe
yeah okay well he is now coming rook d6
now you have to play it no you're not no
you don't you can play this you can play
this with 30 seconds oh nice clean it
and then what Queen age three and then
and that's it you can that's a win you
can get your dreads a win captures rook
and it's a win yeah Wow our our friend
Russ finger come our friend this
legendary Wow
Queen blocks pawn this seven yeah come
on man wind up on Queen blocks pawn you
can do it check what's the check for
Queen d7 Queen walk spawn okay okay very
good
Wow our friend Russ finger is so
exciting yeah just capture clean and
Ruby g8 yeah and you have the time to do
stuff captures white is hoping for some
flagging opportunities but I don't see
that happening this is crazy
it's crazy stuff get the King into the
game or just push the pawn and if
he's good man we just have to play just
push push push
I want to see bullet bullet is not so
great but I think he just created the
account although I think he's very low I
think he okay Queen has a bad connection
yeah maybe okay he has a draw yeah no he
just has to avoid the stalemate against
a very strong player that's true yeah
okay oh he will meet him he will meet
him yeah we yeah we believe in him okay
that's nice that's nice okay okay gotta
be careful with the Queen Oh white
offers a draw no I don't for the draw
legendary well he I mean he should mock
him for not resigning but then again
he's wasting precious time oh come on
okay that was that was too much but good
game good game mister rusting girl for
beating such a strong opponent yeah that
was that was crazy
okay so yeah let's continue with this
trend of okay trying to see the nurse
with maybe a less rating yeah mr.
teammate from Nigeria he's super this is
that like game over maybe okay it's
white to move I thought if it's black to
move then it then it is okay so III end
and that's just it
okay you never exchange exchange but
much more time so I would still play
this with black I guess oh okay Wow is
that is that Bishop going to be captured
or what Wow no this is good this is good
you can always capture the bishop
keeping the tension yeah keeping the
tension okay I'm very interested in the
next move
yeah it might even be 86 yeah it could
be could be 86 you know keeping the
tension okay you know Queen captures
also also works what he went for Queen D
for like checkmate enough to what is
this
maybe the king could but that's that's
strange if he couldn't have castle or
something no it's just I would think
that the player who has 2000 reigning
points on leeches would notice for five
moves that you can capture in detail
with a point yeah we're just with a
weird position maybe someone maybe
someone could explain before saying that
there actually is no pawn on c3 that
it's a bug what really no no that I
guess they are joking yeah they could be
I mean they although it would explain a
lot
yeah I did oh he's opponent berserk
so our opponent see maybe we see the
pawn and c3 and there isn't no it's here
it's the pawn is there okay let's see
the real issue it had the rook went
through it Oh from c1 okay come on yeah
we just you know does some crazy stuff
and this is not a real end game Wow why
dad why dad no okay he can capture and
then III with g3 so not not now up if he
captures on f5 okay he will save the
form
okay there is no c3 pawn no you know oh
then it's like definitely lost there
there is no spoons yeah this is no draw
okay so the the pond isn't really there
here's one second so it will be a draw I
guess okay yeah so but we got a draw
tima had a really good chance to win
this game okay doesn't matter we're
still hanging in there let's see mr.
Robin mr. Robin SJP
what bug does leeches have in store I
don't know what was that is that
correcting next to me no but but a lot
of people say young resembles cardiac
and quite a lot and they mean by his
chest skills yes of course yeah okay
white is doing remarkably well here
Robin is going against a strong opponent
that h6 is he considering some sneaky
idea oh yeah we mosey six yeah very nice
an e6 now oh I thought II 6 okay and
with maybe and queen eight sick later
but Emma will be play itself rule of
course go after g6 but Knight f6 he can
also block yeah but okay Knight e4 and
you have the DF 6 square covered maybe
oh very nice threaten the Queen as well
yes yes and now d6 yeah wins back the
piece no because simply my d6 ah yeah of
course ah
those Knights what is definitely much
better here yes
what's that that's ignore that yeah
maybe 95 and that's it I would go night
night g3 Knight h5 check
I won't even like play a b5 now you
opened up the a file
how about late how about 93 not h5 check
Oh see that's like could be reasonable
could be a movie checkmate Wow Wow why
why okay we can still do this no weekend
okay yeah he has a decent rating and
and then a phone call Wow I'm gonna see
he will gamble out this one who is the
most beautiful girlfriend or nipple what
is that like a thing on the channel I
don't know and I have no idea okay good
good effort Robin you're a nice opening
but it was a winning position but yeah
you know a few more moves to take it all
the way Kershaw stands which I would
assume that this guy is somewhere from
around our parts yeah playing against a
very strong opponent has a very I guess
it's a nice attack it's a weird position
but those that's a bishop here from hail
black ass and that's are we bringing bad
luck to people but 20 seconds on the
clock Wow okay seven rokoff's seven
genius genius old capture capture Queen
g8 checkmate nice Wow Wow
beautiful beautiful stuff beautiful
stuff gracious transition I think we're
four much more invested now that we have
people yeah like oh not not like on the
other stream haha we got people in the
team Russ finger saw the game okay we
haven't seen the Dmitriy smash from
Greece Dimitri's math math I don't know
if it's if it's a Greek math it could be
something else I was that was a
spectacular game yeah yeah boring goes
boring go
he's a very exciting player Oh
Dimitri is taking it oh okay what he
berserk against the 2,300 I don't think
he reserved yes he did there's the the
swords out there okay
well that's okay
very brave brave but well maybe start
Burger King again okay I mean maybe he's
like extremely strong he just never
played on leeches that could also be the
case could be kids 39 okay kid 39
against the Winchester also 35 yeah
maybe there are friends yeah
so kid is what it's not game over
I wonder the Queen up hip removed yeah
we'll take it okay so a lot of people
are streaming we could say so pretty
much everyone is streaming on my
streamer team battle there is no there
there was no mystery team yeah they did
announce the mystery team I thought
maybe Carson's office bill would play
but you know they are probably preparing
for the Tata Steel kuba Devitt okay so
he defended against mate but now rook g6
is coming no it's not but still it's an
exchange he had to do it yeah but was
coming okay so now it's just a clean win
I would even play g5 at that point but
okay yeah it's not necessary what are
creating weaknesses when you're up
material but g5g for it's the tempo and
okay you open up everything and now that
rook is going where I think that goes to
da whoa nice find it's a nice fine but
there is no follow-up yeah but still
yeah okay for the Queen trade it
deserves what he wanted he's up material
he wants to trade down okay now he's
giving up material that's a strange way
to do it and II six is being threatened
mmm-hmm I like white now it's a I have
to be careful very careful with how do
you activate that rope that rope should
have gone to d8 right away I mean what
Ditu Oh
okay now Rudy one this accent yeah now
the other brook enters the game okay how
I see it is maybe maybe rookie for now
yeah
threatens the capture 85 not really a
four he's opening up position now rugby
six is coming and you will not be able
to further defend the pawn so that phone
is but okay there are some counter there
is some comfortable yeah if we have to
lens then anything can happen okay now
it's just yeah but I'll have
independence yeah okay this is not bad
okay King gate rate and that's it yeah
King h8 and attack the the Queen oh ok
queen of seven has to be played yeah but
then there are then there are devious
tricks but okay Queen a4 is a threat win
a four wins the game yeah which rook f1
that's it yeah simple yeah F pawn pinned
Wow our friends our friends in the team
are beating some higher rated players
very nice that's uh that's a good mate
very nice
so bond a couple of points and then
deliver me then let's show the board so
Chris book did ok does leave for sixty
yeah there are definitely in there but
we are still in the game for for the top
penguin is playing penguin is playing
what isn't just not fair
but he still has less points than our
Eddie maybe he started later or
something okay doesn't matter okay are
looking good I would say have I ever
been in Greece yes I have I have been in
Greece Daniel okay Daniel is definitely
his favorite here is 1802 I would say
yeah and the doesn't the second part of
the year yeah that's what the bees for
yeah be yeah
or maybe like yeah there's no be yeah
maybe somebody had a yeah there are
mothers Daniels it like a very popular a
popular handle yeah what I I don't
really know anything that happened in
1802 1802 we started getting a lot of
people in the world you know this
demographic boom a lot of aha okay
they're like we reach the first billion
like the beginning of the 19th century
or something like that
okay they're like that that's the boom
so he's a he's a Boomer okay ikura so
you have to explain the joke we can't
have every joke about every openings go
the same you know we already do that
about the English opening greetings from
Turkey mr. Kerem okay so what do we have
here a pretty stable position white okay
that's a weird move b5 if you ever wanna
push c5 but well I guess he didn't want
to play a farm and he needed to defend
the polonaise know the deponents on b7
right ya know on b-66
you need to defend I guess but you just
push c5 maybe Bishop a6 and rock a rock
a it goes after the a three-pound and b5
done and if you lock lock in division
okay okay but then you then you capture
on d4 or something I think it's gonna be
weird playing this with being unable to
push c5 I like white better here so much
yeah
my dear would be to maybe a little bit
expand on the kingside maybe make some
breathing room and attacking chances oh
yeah definitely it's not gonna be okay
that's uh it's a blunder or is it yes
and he already resigns wow that's a
great great resign I mean a person who
likes 1802 wouldn't do that yeah I would
say like okay doesn't matter
yeah it happens we can't win everyone
exactly okay we have KJ from India
he's our as I understood it it's very
late in India right yeah should be
should be so when you wanna stay awake
you play chess okay so let's see how he
goes against this French variation with
the with the weird Bishop on g4 okay so
we started as a caro-kann but it yeah I
went into this French okay so it's a
this is the variation when White doesn't
know that's not the way you want to do
it I won't you say yeah I want to say
that's the variation where you don't
want to sacrifice any pawns in the
opening but then he did anyway well okay
it's good it's good White King is too in
the center you have the bishop pair for
now no not anymore
Queen g5 yeah yeah go for everything
Quinn g5 when you five th one what you
want
I mean how bad you have to play g6 you
play no he doesn't my juice okay oh no
you're not castling kingside you're not
castling kingside ever Queen d8 right
mmm
yeah but then you're not cancelling
anywhere you just move the Queen Queen
g3 and you push it away probably eight
sixteen wow I like white
I like white what is nice here okay I
hope he doesn't treat Queens that would
be just wheelin 23 I will
playin g3 queen III we know queen g3 is
better I think it is and not okay now he
has neither for ya know he doesn't know
he doesn't o.o open she fell Bishop d6
maybe should have been played first and
now double rooks on the C file yeah you
don't have Roxy for unfortunately but
Roxy 7 looks nice but after Knight f4
you can't really don't see it and don't
take Queen g3 don't like Queen g3 it's
frigid for ya it was a good game it was
a good game yeah yeah he saw everything
except the queen g3 yeah we started
hoping but still he has a lot of
pressure on the Seif well I don't think
he's gonna resign this what what's that
that's a poem yeah but how are you going
to get your rook into the game now but
okay you cannot capture on g7 now you
can actually but you know with age four
it's very difficult to play this game
okay for me forest coming or he's gonna
capture maybe but queen of for fifth
month or Queen e2 I would play Queen e2
we enough to even better yet but he
blocks oh no he can't the bishop guards
at ha we're actually good here we're
good here no like his okay I mean yeah
we've seen two minutes over Roxy to end
it's over you have to go bishop yeah
nope you you're done here you have to
push g5 okay it's 1:20 a.m. in India
yeah it's probably very tired okay but
maybe he just woke up
so or maybe he threw the yeah it's a
nice check midnight checkmate too bad he
missed that queen g3 idea yeah hi -
Aruna whoever Aruna is sky folk Skyfall
let's see
Skyfall vs. SOI korolenko interesting
let's see what happens
I'm very good I don't want to say it
without knocking on what but I'm glad we
are not breaking the stream anymore so
it's not stopping or resuming or
anything yeah I don't know well what
what happened I'm quiet yeah he's just a
bit further away from the microphone I
think this should fix it now and I like
my weight back position yeah very nice
chair it's a good chair yeah I hope one
day to have two good chairs but that
they still hasn't arrived this day could
be tomorrow yeah but I just dreamed so
rarely you know it seems like a waste to
getting another chair yeah but he's a
very good house so I always get the
chairs always that's that's how I roll
very nice thank you for that anytime
yeah I think we need some more apple
juice more not beer alright thank you
sir here it is okay so Skype folk here
does have a very interesting position
with planning on with indeed defended by
the e point yeah and it could be a very
strong pawn unless f6 is possible that's
why Bishop f5 is great yeah I like
White's position and they are looking ok
well not yet no I would play Knight d4
now 94 yeah so if f6 I can go night II 6
maybe yes yeah ok that's interesting we
have to play
you forward f3 yeah see - I would also
go see - no Justin's on f6 now do you
capture on g6 that's true okay but f6
has to be played I mean if he if he
doesn't play it it's just gonna be weird
okay but now now e6 I think e 6 is now a
full go
really yeah II 6 he has to capture and
there's no other way around at night
captures rook has to move yeah it's yeah
yeah hangs on g6
yeah bishop g6 or maybe you don't even
have to capture right away but he will
of course why not okay
creating a passed pawn captured capture
capture he who captures and how do you
okay
what's the point you go after the bishop
go bishop yeah I would have gone better
eh maybe because then c3 is also coming
going form 896
ah okay oh this is this is getting good
and I think our good friends Skyfall is
a long time okay but he isn't interested
in the pawn
okay he is check very much interested in
checkmate where is the King off to now
kingi is he getting checkmated not yet
but if but there are no checkmate
sexually there are always check mates
are there you just have to look okay so
be - Ruby - definitely but then maybe
look if seven is dangerous
94 rook f7 is an all-in ah what sneaky
9400 play not of thinking no here's a
long time so we cannot really expect
yeah I thought I thought he would have
gone for rook f7 and all in but then he
has you know with the g6 with everything
and there should be three is also okay
not anymore but
okay I'm very impressed how he's playing
this maybe five okay no okay oh yeah oh
yeah good game mr. sky folk against uh
against a high rated opponent it was a
good game it was a nice try mr. capybara
says what is going on here well we are
in the middle of the well exactly in the
middle of almost so fifty-five minutes
have passed and we're holding fifth
place which is not bad yeah Eddie is
holding the fort with 54 points in first
place yeah I think Eddie is the the
strongest okay but crest book just love
has Rebecca Harris that's that's insane
okay we can even see here what is the
current situation with okay you cannot
see it because yeah but okay we can it's
better if we just check games sure let's
see
minions okay it's a it's a minion minion
Dee yeah okay a very let's see the
position he's playing with the black
pieces use opponent berserk and okay
Jack is this some sort of a cool puzzle
rush maneuver okay how will he do it
h5 follow hot the knight is under attack
if I may quote you he wants the knife to
move Queen h5 check and push the passed
pawn now Queen h5 check and then you
push the pawn okay but Queen e1 and you
lose the pond now he will win the night
now you win the game no well Queen d1
with twenty five is possible now that's
a good King that's a good King okay
Queen d1 no okay what's a queen d1 now
Queen d1 checking okay okay
this also works he has what okay I give
up no no he didn't queen g6 but he a
queen g6 of oh that's that's why queen
d1 wow what's that
what but it doesn't work it's checkmate
it's gonna be checkmate oh no yes it is
Wow he was hoping for Ruby g8 the Queen
d1 that should have been played yeah
unfortunately
weird Wow ah that's too bad that's too
bad but it was a valiant attempt yeah
nevertheless let's move on okay
I already saw his game was from Italy we
haven't seen his game but I do remember
him oh nice nice
mega mega to Code noob says he got made
it on move 11 that's okay you'll get him
next game trying to make it until move
12 next time that should be the goal
okay we are almost we'll see yeah we
will we play some games later yeah I
know how busy on schedule is definitely
oh definitely at 10 p.m. on a Thursday
yeah the busiest of times okay
so what do we have here there should be
six okay that's a nice dish up there if
you can you know
yeah get it go yeah but he's doing but
why it's attack is getting very
dangerous okay he wants to he's greedy
he's very greedy I like it okay capture
capture and win the pawn so White has
nothing anymore mmm okay yeah sure he
could play off six buddies what no what
was that always captured I wants to play
c5 but that's just too slow pretty much
every situation where you can capture
the pawn in the center and pretty much
kill yeah especially the one that's
coming for you yeah opponents attack
should be a go-to move
yes hmm let's play actually against
pepper Liu who is streaming
so he's absolutely streaming featured on
two streams at the same time oh wow
that's that's a good that's a good deal
yeah very nice yeah I'm wondering I'm
wondering if there's any information on
how many people are streaming this
tournament like I know you can go to
twitch but not everyone is using twitch
okay that's a that's a weak g3 square we
should go there right now
yes eighty five ninety three okay he
wants to prepare okay for something
maybe there should be eight no okay
yeah but still please play push a beat
no there should be five and now he's
gonna give it up there's no night age
five okay all right I think anything can
happen here he's gonna pull the phone
that seems he seems unlikely that this
will work but who knows what are those
numbers on the leaderboard how many how
many points each player scored from the
top twenty who who scored well yeah okay
Knight g5 knight of seven yeah seven is
just great
okay the c-pawn suddenly came to see
bond is there but i don't think i don't
see it maybe you could see some
sacrifices at sample we have one rook F
1 and C naught C 1 but King h8 no key
then 907 yeah but okay you capture no
okay he's going for it is there anything
here I'm sure there is but neither Sun
King of fates and then you have or you
don't have any discoveries because Queen
kevro's exactly yeah so weird weird
position I think that maybe less has
turned it around or night of three
and then you somehow defend the Rockwood
but one out of three check me can you
etch it and then night h2 no there's
just two queens I thought maybe there
was something but no it's very nice
he's going for it King f8 and there's no
move King f8
yeah I hope doesn't capture with the
Queen I really hope he doesn't he cannot
because his check okay good that's good
it's good that he cannot play this
illegal move black is definitely winning
I agree but it's not it's bullets time
so okay capture character and you're
good yeah it's okay that's that's
dangerous it's mighty well not all that
clear I mean night he got 496 you know
he can captured rook in the night
oh no check me no oh oh good meat good
meat we have to congratulate our
opponents team as well I mean true it
was there it was about 25 I like I saw
that immediately saw that it's not
working Queen g5 so did from c1 you
could have captured the night
immediately we could the other Queen was
here and then there is no checkmate yes
it's the chess is ruthless yeah
unfortunately it is okay we are still
hanging on in fifth place
so definitely good and it's right about
time to check ok mr. cool kangaroo both
of them reserves
how many winning positions can our team
blunders a lot well we still have an
hour to go yeah other teams have have
some GM's but it's it's ok it's better
for us if there are GMC and other teams
because there then our teammates get to
play against James and their teams don't
you know you can also look at it that
way
and I gotta say when we are looking at
games from players from our team we
definitely don't know what will happen
yeah with always the same something
anything can happen and that's a night
that's a good night okay you kick it
away tonight goes somewhere and okay I
like white prom date yeah yeah nope he
just gave him that no no he gave him to
double his rooks okay oh so he will
rather do that capture it now I like
white okay but that's now what you see
with black is better black is better
here why would black be better because
the King because of the active King yes
but okay I don't know if that's now even
know the winning move was d4 here yeah I
think not no but I'm for him but hmm now
it's a difficult because white has d4
pawn yeah but black will I be able to
outmaneuver him yeah maybe yeah black
cool yeah yeah yeah black black wins
this black no wins
unfortunately for cool kangaroo although
I don't know the Kings are very close no
he will be three then you play a four
with f3 and then the King yeah he has to
wait for for the King to move yeah
that's just that's a game I mean at that
point it doesn't really matter yeah but
our friend the cooking guru will try to
use some flagging techniques prove that
eight point if you want to stalemate
pull the ape okay
[Music]
okay let's see let's check out Barbara I
don't know m'kay yeah you have been
noticed sir okay what do we have here
barb and while versus feed a master and
if chess okay
well black wins this yeah yeah captures
captures and then times Darwin's win
good game
yeah we it was a good and short viewing
of the game yeah good endgame let's see
is there any prize for the winners yes
the bragging rights until the next team
team battle so that's the only prize -
no like first yeah I don't know how
would they actually give the money away
because maybe top 20 players you mean
yeah but that was the point of the team
thing you know I don't know that's why I
would prefer if maybe 50 top 50 is
scored not top 20 but even maybe maybe
be hard to keep count
this way they want to promote elite
players to join not not make it like a
large scale team event just want to say
mob for from the team I guess tomorrow
yeah his winning is waiting yes okay
anymore oh and here's winning yeah and
now he can give and he can play Queen
before Queenie for and can't play
Queenie Fido or Queen see it yeah okay
he's gonna try and find a sneaky mate I
know it mmm
maybe he's gonna for Queen c4 and
capture the pawn yeah could be could be
yeah but the petition for allow
Queenie's Bishop e6 the official plans
on e6 then those bishops will be hard to
do outmaneuver
Quincy for was a better he's going for
f2 he wants to grab the f2 pawn and
that's it yeah unless Luke d8 I know
there still is no back rank made since
the bishop covers f1 but Igor the legend
will we'll try something most definitely
yeah some legendary move okay hmm keep
first capture on a3 okay and then we'll
capture enough to will he now okay but
that's very sneaky pawn is that your
sister yes yes mr. Linder dead that is
my sister Ruby
now I don't know okay could be could be
huh you never know hello mister smash
thank you thank you for joining the
stream okay this is taking way longer
than it should but that just shows you
the power of the bishop pair or the
power of the three plus oh yeah okay
that pawn is going places and now we
just shouldn't wander back rank mate
Bishop yeah it's okay but see f1 was a
go King if one seems like a good move
Babu is playing with fire here yeah okay
Queen of fate no okay rook f8 finally
okay and now win that bring the king
bring the king yes and okay and I push
the pawn and win whose opponent win done
trying to sneaky ideas classic yeah he's
gonna try and hide away
push the other pawn as well yeah that's
always sneaky mr. king
sure checkmate there it is no that's not
that's not it
now it is yes alright a good good
for for mobile yeah all right we're
doing extremely well
only player doing better than it is
actually really good yeah it's very good
okay better than him our only only
Rebecca Harris and mr. Abdul Abdul Kadir
let's check out the game from a period
theatrical there they come Kirikou okay
yeah our team member reserved
okay which is what you should do
he played that for thus winning a piece
yeah
so pretty much all bases covered so it's
winning
yeah there's no no oh yeah if there is
indeed there was no me win was the Queen
was guarding it but what would you play
captures 995 with what with the pawn
that attack tonight but Queen captures
only - the Queen was unguarded ah the
Queen was unguarded oh well then yes so
okay that we it's gonna be difficult
with 43 seconds but that's what was
berserkers live for yeah so still doable
I would say it is doable if if mr. Ayers
dog Lou plays bad but okay yeah go for a
Fuji for Rudy to g4 Rudy to first I want
to play route d7 he won't allow it
of course g4 no right it's gonna be
different it's it's good for white but
the time is the issue
yeah and he wants to trade rooks he goes
into this end game where g5g g five
should have been played you want to
block the pawns on white squares it's in
such an end game hmm
okay he's now gonna try and gobble up
the pawns on the Queen side but the
knight will not let him yeah he wants to
he's gonna place he can't play c6 that's
good
okay you should have gone he would have
gone and and tried it yeah at this point
check and see for no I don't see it I
don't see it
yeah well it's a lot of bad luck for for
our teammates yeah unfortunately
yeah but that's that's what it is what
it means the berserk it so it's never
easy I mean there are still some yeah if
he does ability 3 yeah he he he decided
not to go King g3 for some reason that's
winning yeah I have no idea why I didn't
go King g3 and grab the phone ok ok but
there will be a lot of pre moving now
you know has to move the bishop no yeah
it's good it's good yeah but and one
time yeah
and now in now Queen f3 and matin f1 yes
nice good job good job with so little
time on the clock that's the stuff
very nice any people that only want to
watch the show I think most people do we
haven't seen a game from Caloocan
cloaking clocking 937 what is your
height my height that's like last time I
checked which was some 15 years ago was
191 centimeters
I think that's six point three inches
but I'm not an inch person so I could be
wrong
you're not an inch person yeah no not
inches feet
[Laughter]
okay so what do we have here again there
was no berserk in here but it's a it's a
difficult position
so Queen yeah Quincy two didn't work
because Bishop to a5 we have actually
two very strong players playing against
each other I would say strong players
well yeah I mean that that is a good
rating so material is equal black does
have oh okay okay
there's no sir there's a move now you
have to really figure out what to do I
mean it's not a sacrifice
okay how about capturing capturing and
going something likes it yeah that's
what I was thinking but I'm sure it can
be defended oh he met Queen b6 but when
g5
yeah if Queen c2 he probably would have
pushed the Jeep on and then the Queen
defense okay but I like when she's sick
yeah okay the rook is under attack so
what yeah but also this rook and you
lose the energy h3 pawn is also under
attack Queen h4 very nice move
Wow okay pretty much seals the deal no
it doesn't
yeah with Queen h3 he still wants to
push his past pony for Queen trade
occurs with his nine seconds
Brooks III and push Rocky 397 okay rook
e3 and that's it unfortunately it was
good good while it lasted
he's gonna still try and play this well
I I guess you have to do that if you
want a rating you know people will make
mistakes okay so he's going for
stalemate no he's not yeah okay was a
good game okay now yan pick one will
react
we win should I choose Eddie let's
choose someone from the middle then to
door to door from Romania okay I missed
no then that's not our team sorry
[Laughter]
bridge for okay with no worry to door
bridge is not on our team on our team
it's a gap of Alexander really yeah but
you already opened it yeah I know okay
I know it's great okay Bridge it's gonna
be this is gonna be an epic battle look
at those pawns so okay that was a there
was a good capture let's let's show them
that the Forth Bridge is the best one of
them all okay
no there should be two but through K 2
and now interesting position
I thought he would have gone for Queen
b6 instead of saving the visual but Oh
in b6 I told you
roots III game okay we have to do
something about that
f2 pawn Queen c7 yeah routes it to and
now okay good good stuff you just have
to make some breathing room for the king
before you try anything
Louise okay okay yeah breathing room for
the king and now now even yeah okay now
that the knight moves rook F to works
followed by Bishop b3 maybe but no
they're too fast okay that's but Queen
g8 Queen g8 no man Yana I told you one
where we win okay it's a good good one
definitely good checkmate okay just not
be sure Thank You mr. Traylor for the
contribution thank you sir let's see
alpha zero
if alpha zero doesn't win alpha zero
three six nine
okay alpha zero is taking this one look
at those pass pawns
hmm although it's not the real alpha
zero he hasn't pushed his H pawn at all
Wow that that night doesn't really have
a good square and now the King becomes
active captures Nagi three no he's gonna
give up these two pawns and we grab
these two he's playing against the
Yaroslav no more each right he's and now
yeah
King activate the King you have to do it
but it's a draw it's a draw with two
extra points I mean yeah at this point
the King will make it in front and I
think you can't really win this with
white I think white will win this it's a
it's a bullet game now yeah 94 he will
capture the pawn but yeah and now comes
check with grabbing the pawn and 2 2
extra port as pawns win nope
okay drew 3-3 and then you play it and
now okay
still still 494 Knight f6 I mean yeah
night at 5 okay maybe we'll learn
something it would be interesting if our
player played h3 and then 92 is check
okay and that would be great
yeah then I would decide that to be the
tournament director anymore yeah the
King cannot go out which is I'm sure he
can but do you need to give up a pawn so
yeah but our player is also low a long
time okay now it's better now it's
better no kh4 all right okay and now we
have him we're
we want him yeah yeah neither for grab
some room for the king
he's going after our g3 pawn okay very
nice defend I think he could have just
captured now captures captures and went
for the h3 pawn so easy draw I think our
player will lose some time yeah I think
that's that's where this is going yeah
sacrifice the night for the pawn and
that's it okay now we have some extreme
free move action here yeah which is not
going to end well I believe for us this
is gonna result in someone no I think
he's not just going to move the knife
really fast or the king yeah that's
definitely a weird just spawn g3 a
couple times already
okay but still if you don't feel
comfortable being up a pawn or two you
you trade down into an endgame which
draw maybe but yeah it's it's a tough
one when you actually play okay it's a
close one between our team and penguins
team but we're also very close to
Charlotte yeah I mean stooop happen yeah
obviously
how many 37 minutes to go okay okay
storks Oryx has climbed all the way to
the top will be a tournament without a
psychopath
okay look at the game intros look at the
game you chose that's all yeah that's
just disgusting I don't know maybe I
shouldn't choose games and maybe we
would be in the first place no no I
doubt that but let's see okay so it's
and this will be played out all right
good stuff good stuff
okay no I'm gonna go to Eddie okay Eddie
the Savior who is Eddie up against and
we are Vivek Varma from the first move
almost so far Eddie is four to one
against
he's in fourth place also in the
tournament Eddie
ah by points yeah yeah very nice he's
playing some sort of uh yeah I don't
know who chief I was the Bishop g5 Tory
attack Tory attack yeah but I like white
woody for will be played oh well these
are 2600 player 94 Bishop is yeah very
good very good systems he five no I
don't think we'll guess a single move
here maybe okay even Bishop captures on
f6 first oh oh oh the main threat and
that is how he does it 26 right quinces
war do you want to leave black the
bishop I mean that about that seven the
bishop is super strong but captures
captures and Queen captures rook know
what he couldn't capture on e7 without
dying oh yeah it's a resigned because
the rook hangs
yeah but Bishop d7 and Bishop e7 and
Queen d7 and then you move the Queen oh
yeah good yeah it's a good game any
demands
all right yes nice okay let's check out
who's second saw Rex or X okay let's do
another circle huh yeah those guys
deserve holding his own managing also if
he takes down Chicago that's that's
cause for celebration
yeah we'll open up some champagne
yes resource against everyone he's uh
okay here he is twenty-seven
twenty-eight hundred almost in bullet I
think he got to 3200 at 1.30 to yeah he
constantly plays both OH
oh but uh butts Oryx is a rook up yes
and he's a minute up so should be good
right should be good but 92 okay night
p2 night a to or e to regardless which
okay very nice I win against G Galka he
takes down the Grandmaster yes excellent
stuff
who is sorex I don't have a title yeah
someone from Italy have a good score
against him too - for who you really is
probably bullets or hyper bullets yeah
two to four okay pewter no right there
with no because now okay but we took a
point from the leading team we're not
trying to catch up to the leading team
okay what do we have here pewter is
looking good but he has 25 seconds on
the clock oh you said it you said it and
it's a resign those are quick games yeah
those are beyond bullet okay who's in
first place
oh we haven't seen a game from our
ignorant non deflector 797 okay against
me cayó mm he is winning okay but that
team should keep an eye on the F pawn
not sure that's the way to go h5 he's
waiting for Weiss to do something on the
queenside yeah it's a it could be a
droid ah yeah okay okay no he can start
grabbing points good stuff okay and he
pushes capture and push so what can be
done here nice
yeah but it's not that a nice I mean
nothing really happens it's okay
it's a check and now it's a queen
opponent game where our player is again
down a minute but it's because he
berserk
okay he's now gonna Massacre him with
checks this is not looking good
yeah it will be how long okay
and he yeah yeah he's not gonna try and
hide his king and then he will most
likely blunder the Queen no he trades
Queen Queen before yeah yeah but he
missed it
yes again Queen before mr. Langan
inflictor whatever that means
yeah it's Burger King it's it's a
serious sport TomTom okay we have two
wins and two losses in a very short time
yeah let's go for another win
Tom Tom versus feeding master mighdal
Tom Tom has problems on the GFL but it's
not all that bad I would say Bishop g4
what is berserk berserk King is when you
give well get rid of half of your time
but you get extra points for a win in
short yeah join the team and win some
games but no we are we are doing
remarkably well if you consider how how
how how strong the other teams are yeah
okay okay okay okay fair fair fair King
g5 and I it's all good it's not the best
but I mean c3 d4 will be played captured
capture yeah but also he gets rid of his
passport a double spawn yeah we'll see
ah el Cohen no that's not how it works
since only the scores from the top 20 a
point scores count towards the final
score so it doesn't matter we do have
the biggest team that's not not an issue
but only the top 20 scores count that's
that's how it works
interesting can I talk into some gems
for the next tournament yeah I could but
it's I don't know I decided not to talk
to anyone make it and make it a you know
purely a subscribers tournament okay put
the room behind the past pawn push the a
pawn and hope for the best and go and
get made it but king in the game
captures now the problem was at Tom Tom
hmm
unfortunately don't get made it King
these six okay push No
okay he found he found a way okay
threefold yeah it's a good draw a good
draw against the 2500 player very nice
TomTom Frogner
Ronia alright from there a lot of people
with 45 points against unsub Ouroboros
actually a good position this pawn on d3
is looking very good
oh yeah boy why shouldn't it be nice it
read some point you push f6 get your
king to d6 and push it 500 nice Knight
c3 no d2 yeah
Knight c3 Bishop e2 or that no no need
for that now you cannot sure you can
disappear - yeah Bishop e2
yeah the same oh he wants to make it
cool sorry okay night-night blocks with
check and you promote one yes don't let
him grab your Queen that's how it's done
beautiful Queen wants to make it with
tempo and queen g1 checkmate huh yeah
that's what they say
King anywhere and it's mate okay he can
prolong with that no it doesn't okay
check grab the g2 pawn make him suffer
yeah all right
just so you know you can still join the
tournament and still play and join our
team just click on the links in the
description below so you will be ready
for for the next tournament when it
comes yeah good job good job man good
job okay alright we're doing very well 9
9 13 of 0 bridge for robe and our arm we
haven't seen a game from arm
yeah all right
playing against a player who berserk
excellent League I look like a toad
Peter Dinklage I I think I don't know if
he's talking to me but I think he is
since so a lot of people say that yeah
yeah but okay you get the cardigan yeah
and I think our stream just died
today I don't know it's just watching
zero so it could be either death or or
everyone left yeah no no no more of this
yeah it's too much too much of chess
yeah it didn't die okay so then it's
just a bug I guess so thank you for that
I know maybe it's the the new thing
YouTube's been doing so since so uh you
know teenagers are struggling with their
view count you know they are you know
they don't feel good if they stream and
no one's watching so I know that
Instagram started doing things like that
like you post a photo on Instagram and
you don't see if people liked the photo
or how many people liked it really yeah
for the either for the first day or
something like that I think you're super
fresh elliptic for your contribution and
maybe maybe YouTube decided to do as
well I think it's a great idea since I
don't really you know care all that much
but you know younger people would care
definitely okay no okay
still doesn't make sense but thanks for
the explanation yeah because you know
when teenagers you know post something
on Instagram day they keep refreshing
you know to see who liked their photo
okay so now Instagram says no we will
not let you do that anymore
you're welcome to use our platform but
you know post a photo and then go take a
walk okay okay it's an interesting I
guess yeah concept but yeah we'll see
how they intend to like keep it maybe in
the future or what yeah I think it's
where everything is going towards okay
but I don't think they implemented it
where III think Australian fermented it
and I think California available
somewhere yeah make sense okay but kids
when we were discussing our player did
win the game okay I'm not that Jinxy
after all and now we're looking at a
game from yes sir and easy oh okay he's
playing against a much higher rate of
the point but that so did the last guy
yeah he won so okay this one is down the
exchange would check this looks pretty
bad but okay but if Queen b6 check is
possible and you can get your queen
today okay what's that kind of six maybe
some just just exchange no it's not it's
uh he wants to grab the rook yeah he
wants to just exchange rooks in that
yeah I would have given a check just to
see where he goes but then you can no
longer in yeah yeah but now it's just
Rakesh eight rotate mm-hmm that's pretty
bad so Queen b6 was perhaps still better
yeah give one more check before you lose
yeah huh okay we still in fifth place
very close okay Eddie in sixth very nice
and Rebecca Harris off as expected in
first with a hundred and seventeen
points that's that's brutal
okay mister JJ yeah national master why
why why why 23:24 okay let's see how he
does
been playing against Camel Clutch sure
make make a under 2000 tournament next
time for your subs I think that could be
extremely interesting yeah but then I
still think people would just make
second accounts to play yeah it could be
so it's never fair yes and we still have
to wait for the end of the tournament
until all the cheaters are filtered out
if there are any Thank You mr. science
all for a contribution thank you sir
then you do like a 100 game minimum yeah
100 game minimum but then then if
someone doesn't plan Li chess it's
impossible for them to make an account
and play the tournament it's also not
not yet another great solution yeah
pretty much
restricting it only to people who are
playing yes so it's a bit of an elitist
decision but it is lishus what do you
capture on g6 and on f6 here is their
with what I don't know no whatever it is
no I won't capture on e5 as well ok yeah
the camel Fletcher found a good move
yeah yes he didn't got to say yeah 50
game requirement is is decent yeah he
did it that's what I wanted to do sooner
ok but it makes sense when the queen is
on f6 of course oh he made a he made a
room for Bishop g4 but Asia 3 yeah I
don't mean this he goes into a better
end game doesn't really have to think
too much yeah
that he has more time ok could you
forward check I think he played b3 in
hopes mr. camel clutch sure would resign
since b3 is such a strong move oh but he
didn't he wanted to emphasize how strong
yeah and in the position he's still
waiting for the for the e6 capture an a6
capture yeah
doesn't really care about the pond yeah
oh he's going for the f5 square with the
night I like it beautiful
there's nobody move here except moving
the rook or the King still Knight a5 c3
or something Caesar okay okay I see it
okay six check yeah this is just this is
just brutal I mean yeah camel clutch
sure with less time and everything
father shoot yeah that's that's that
would be a monster night although it's
such a such a you know hey impressive
endgame that it's not not even needed ok
the pawns are marching forward yeah yeah
of course
don't give him any counter play and mr.
camel clutch or resins good game mister
why why we gave mr. yy-yes positive comp
makedonia positive mmm because I think
we pretty much did we cover all the oh
we didn't the crucial no but I think we
dropped the sixth place were we 5th we
were fifth now we're sixth still very
good still very good yeah six out of
nine is is a good result
yeah it's what is that 2/3 2/3 yeah 66%
okay okay
still you have the capture there's no
other way around it hmm yeah
unfortunately the crucial is now and a
bit of an issue here with the position
yeah that those pawns are doing nothing
he did that why and the bishop is
useless
yeah he just decided to resign
that's the way to do it definitely okay
and the penguin Club went to make it
when you two-point advantage penguin
started playing obviously 18 minutes to
go it's pretty clear who will win the
tournament yeah I think it was clear
before we even started yeah you know now
it seemed clear yeah I think we pretty
much covered all around me - let's go
let's go write me tune right McCune can
even get two games in yeah he definitely
deserves oh what a nice what a nice move
I knew that we have to select the game
right now from there he couldn't capture
because he loses the Queen f5 and 94
probably Wow
yeah f5 94 wins the Queen but that's
Rogers Queen we don't want him to lose
the Queen no Raj is black dude Raj is
black yeah really
all right is black nice right okay we
can do another rush somehow I don't know
it I've never figured it out yeah I
think you can actually just scroll his
name and wait for the game to appear but
you want you I think you have to like re
hover it okay that's that's the stuff
all right it's a good opponent for Raj
let's see our our does Roger skipping is
raining around 2,200 so having a good
tournament yeah going for the center
with three pawns all right you're gonna
be this is gonna be a good game yes
let's see how Raj tackles this probably
probably some nasty Bishop III yeah okay
each three should be to development yes
my name is Sergey Karjakin nice to meet
you yeah I thought it would be nice to
have our Grand Master help out with the
commentary so I invited Sergey yeah yeah
we're good friends in free time with
speaking Russian
and discuss chess theory yes and games
mostly yeah oh yeah
beautiful beautiful queen of 7mate black
offers now draw a game Raj Raj deserves
a third game in my opinion Thank You mr.
Mario - too rich for the contribution
thank you sir
Oh black we'll leave the time running
that's that's just lame yeah that's just
lame he says whose team is he playing
for well do we want to shame him it
doesn't say
yeah but he is from Belarus yeah
it doesn't mean that it really doesn't
mean anything but yeah maybe we I don't
come on man no I think he'll leave the
clock going it's a shame Raj is a good
point accumulator yeah now his aim we
want to keep him on on the roll yeah
okay there is a possibility that he got
disconnected at the point 96 happened
but I think yes yes but tell me can you
join the tournament even if you don't
join a team no at the moment you join a
team it asks you we know at the moment
you can tournament it asks you which
team do you want to join the topic to
play a tournament but then it doesn't
make sense to wait out because you're
not really earning any points yes but
you are you're preventing Raj who is
obviously doing good you know to gain
more points so it's a I think we can go
for another game I think mr. X
Rison will leave the time running out no
he he's doing the the barta laban but
you know what are you gonna do cameras
okay mister gamma X let's see
[Music]
okay he's down a queen and white just
gave up his queen to go into a
completely winning endgames
which is of course fair yeah I think we
can safely choose another game there is
no hope here this is hopeless
I mean to the point okay this is
hopeless so let's let's see arm we saw
arm bridge we saw bridge pure trick
Tom Tom we haven't seen Tom Tom we seen
Tom Tom we have we have okay
and now Raj is starting another game son
okay so it'll rise do a Raj game since
we also the pointless hopefully this
time his opponent will not resign so
easily
alright it's 5 a.m. here in the
Philippines so people are waking up or
there's going to be L not going to sleep
playing against search GD Sergey D
that's like granddad no no the feature
maybe it's a it's a name GD there are
some some names could be yeah ok how
will Roger go about this you'll probably
find a very good move I don't even want
to suggest a ch3 no no no h3 I that's
the first thing I thought of so it can't
be good
he did win a point so yes but if that
one was winnable that'd be really weird
yeah I mean they want it very easily so
I'm questioning the GD fiddle Evita
shout out something so you can go to
sleep man
so the apple juice is definitely kicking
in ah who is Roger you know you guys not
know who Raj is Raj Raj has been on
every stream since I started the channel
and when when I first started my first
stream some three years ago he was
raided around I don't know maybe 1,400
and now he's twenty two hundred so
that's that's a good improving player
right there yeah Raj is a legend Raj is
a legend around these parts yeah Raj
shouldn't have played Bishop c6 now he's
in a position where he needs to give up
upon which is unfortunate and he is in a
rock n game okay but okay I mean this is
still playable but it's very dry you can
play I don't think it's dry I think it's
a draw it's a draw yeah but still okay I
mean okay but with Roxy 707 is the Mafia
he is very comfortable
yeah rookie seven check yeah and then
you go back Roxie seven rookie seven
yeah yeah there is no way to do it yeah
now he goes King f8 Roxie seven or he
might try something else
ah oh I thought he's gonna go rookie
five with a chance to get the Ruby as
the best better because of checkmate
threats
yeah joking of fates withdraw and that's
it okay sir they're still really really
good to play against higher rated
opponent and yet yeah we think he
spotted the mate oh he's gonna prolong
it check him D seven and that's it
that's the game Raj will win Wow he
didn't want to give Raja draw and now
Raj wins Raj the legendary have it
that's why Raj is third year in a row
yeah that that's impressive stuff I'm
very I'm actually very glad that he is
on our team on our team and we are
watching his games yeah I would actually
like to keep this going you think he can
do it I further I think he
and maybe he just jumped up one more
points really or so man yeah okay okay
okay okay one more one more one more and
then we are close to the end of the
tournament are we okay nine minutes yeah
okay Raj is playing against the 2,500
player now so can he do it yes I think
Raj will do it king b1 is the move what
better than to play a Yugoslav attack is
this Yugoslavia Tech dragon with g4 h it
appears to be is and he has to play king
b1 yeah no no way around that I think
the old trick 97 check yeah oh no no not
97 because I can get faith hahaha but
okay yeah okay yeah but it's a it's a
yeah yeah it would be possible if the
rook was on f8 but he quickly played
rook FC 8 yeah yeah yeah that is why I
have to play this rookin see it not yeah
that's which rook goes to the C file ok
captured capturing d5 okay so good good
pawn now B 3 C 4 if you can get that in
that could be very nice but I'll get B 5
is always lurking I don't know why we
are even suggesting anything because ROG
yeah I just so good yeah ok but B 3 C 4
yeah okay destroying the dragon I think
we are looking quite good here yeah and
that's a that's a good-looking Bishop
mm-hmm looking good on time I've put in
c4 yeah I think we wants to commit okay
Oh goes for the e7 point yeah and then
you defend it how Knight b6 night c5
that b6 attacks the point on I d5 well
it's interesting oh he wants to give
night for Bishop okay you know I guess I
guess yeah now 93 is a must
you cannot play 94 really but before you
can play by virtue the week we're so
weak square but but okay what after in
rookie 7s King f6 huh
and yeah I thought he was gonna go with
C 3 it's just a BC position there's but
okay now we see what Rush is made of I
think it's gonna be great b5 and rook c5
okay but rookie for no no he wants to
get b4 b5 in rook c5 c4 you need to play
c4 okay but now you don't have b5
anymore ever king c3 you go in with the
king now go before or even king d4 no I
think before king d4 could be eric d5 no
rush oh oh no it doesn't matter still
not it's so good yeah okay now with now
with Ruby 5 maybe he can do something
try to connect those pawns rugby two and
go for the b7 pawn ah I think yeah open
time so yes that's great just pressure
on just pressure on okay the knight 91
threat of winning the rook I like it
yeah King before but 92 isn't possible
because of this rook Bishop e2
nice and now I would captured on maybe
no rock still wants to figure out if
there's time for something else
beautiful
Bishop b4 REE maneuver to d5 yeah but
now you no longer have control of c4
so this captures rook captures there's a
double attack on c4 think Roger is good
here ROG is always good yeah don't even
have to think about it huh no it's okay
yeah I would play this and capturing
he's going for c4 okay watch 91 I hope
he doesn't go busy for now okay he
doesn't see it
that's it that's two points for black
still yeah oh he's gonna do it he's
going for it
okay I don't think he should have traded
rooks because it would be easier to flag
black with with rooks okay let's see
bring the king yes yes do it bring it f6
does enough okay ah go to with the king
yeah f5 yes not easy not easy
yeah Oh success kingi for the bishop can
stop the e pawn so it's not a problem
Bishop f3 maybe Bishop f3 and that's it
Bishop it's the end block yeah beautiful
yes large the man yeah capture the pawn
okay Oh
incredible game by ROG incredible
beautiful you there a little stuff okay
three minutes to go okay it's only fair
to maybe to give it to Eddie even though
I see his finishing up with the game and
it
you could actually win this yeah yeah
we're getting a position maybe no no
it's not but he will try to get it no no
yes
yeah he can't get it okay but it's an
Instagram master yeah so Italian pitch
chicken all right any bringing in some
some incredible points and Renea middle
I think the last person yeah I don't
think against freedom master elector who
we see this game finished until the end
of the tournament see yeah I think
that's it and I think we've we've done a
solid job a winning sixth place yeah and
when I say we I mean our team yeah good
job guys the next tournament of this
type will be I don't know I guess when
leaches decides to throw one but now
that the teams are formed any team can
create a team battle and if other teams
are interested in participating it
doesn't have to be an official event I
mean it can just happen oh it works like
that yes III I guess I don't know good
me five could be yeah he doesn't want to
play e5 he wants to open the position
why he's King is open okay but okay so
[Music]
so this is like a new thing only chess
no yeah and I guess okay other people
can play against other people's teams
but that's my question
like yeah what does it mean like be a
streamer team from which streamers I
don't know so just say I'm a streamer
and yeah you can apply unleashes to be a
streamer and if you okay so yeah I know
that yeah and and you can even I guess
okay I but I don't know you're another
streamer you cannot I think you can I
I don't think you have to be a streamer
it's it's a team battle it's not a yes
they called it a stream streamer battle
but I don't think in this turn yeah I
don't think it's it's what it actually
is
huh yeah I'm sure I'm sure it will be a
monthly event six plays not very good
[Laughter]
excellent work without we didn't bring
any grandmasters so it's it's incredible
stuff yeah ah crash upbeat Montenegro in
handball okay I was actually planning on
watching that but I had no idea was
today yeah I started and use that all
the people like they're preparing
playing games against Bosnia or someone
they travel to Austria saw that but I
also didn't know the game was today yeah
but okay our team is very good in
handball so I expect second round I
decided not to watch it anymore handball
too many too much stress okay and our
player should win this if should if he's
not getting made that is oh he won't get
made it I don't see it even after nice
king g1 and that's it but time is
running low okay now the knight is
hanging so we have to deal with that and
okay cap check and we'll exchange
everything in this game
rookie six Czech trade no you see six it
would be much easier okay rookie - Rudy
- but yeah he doesn't have counter play
but twenty seconds I mean why do you why
do you take two seconds to recaptures
that's just weird
oh no he started playing yeah push some
push something push upon no captures
yeah now he'll get up th 2 ponyo
hold okay Ruby - Ruby - and that's it
Ruby - okay 99 seconds oh it's okay we
have this we have this Wow okay but yeah
it's it's travel time travel okay it's
not even in a tournament anymore but
yeah or maybe it is is it but time ran
out so no yeah that's where the game is
all weekend but okay view the tournament
is it over I guess it is is it over
there are no like trophies or I don't
know I guess they didn't include that
very close to the fifth place yeah so
very close to the fifth place but
penguins penguins team beat beat us by
by a few points margin 16 points but
sixth place
great I actually thought that we were
being closer to maybe 8th place when we
started but there you have it our Eddie
mashallah is amongst the top ten point
scorers so incredible stuff very nice
we applaud yeah and if you if you look
at how many grandmasters there were like
that's one two three look at that four
five like a lot of grandmasters mm-hmm
okay that's not a lot that's five but
I'm sure there are more well yeah it was
it was definitely a great tournament
listen for for a tournament where there
are no prizes yeah I would say that's
and how many people 5461 okay how many
people in the oven water steam it's
1,000 so yeah yeah a fourth
yeah no not bad well yeah okay so here
are the top scorers we're just gonna
showcase a few of them since you cannot
see them
Eddie mashallah aronia kill kill the
pewter bridge for franken inflict r97
alpha zero three six nine a large
Mattoon is in seven place incredible
incredible stuff ROG arm ESS pure trick
to 12 TomTom oh one two five pun hair
national master YY - three - four then
feed a master Sookie 71 the Jonatan
minions Robin SJP crash of stunts reach
the crucial Rick stick no rice stick and
F dolt those are the top 20 scores with
a lot a lot more to follow
so really incredible stuff and thank you
all for for joining our team and
achieving such a such a great result
so sixth in the end not bad and I don't
think there were cheaters here yeah I
don't know what would be the reason yeah
there are no prizes and given there's
never reason I mean it's not like you're
gonna win the tournament so there's
always like that idea in your head when
you're cheating I guess that you won't
get caught you know yeah I don't think
that's the case here since you know
you're not being caught by a human
you're being caught by an algorithm and
also what what Lance says thanks so much
the Thibeault and Alicia's team for
making the new fantastic kind of the
tournament
thanks to all streamers players and
viewers that there was well said mr.
Lance yeah I agree
it's always nice to have I don't know
how it is on other websites but it's
good that leaches is trying to figure
out new ways how to entertain us think
of new like types of tournaments and
everything yeah I think everyone tries
to do that it's just this is a website
where everything is always free and as
they say in their motto and it always
will be
so that's that's also nice yeah
okay I would also like to congratulate
of course all the players that were
playing also all the players that are
playing for the team the top 20 looks
nice I think we pretty much showed gains
from all not all I see not all but most
of the players from the top 20 yeah so
and maybe it's not a good idea maybe to
make it a 2 plus so next time sure I am
NOT bullet of course but I think 2 plus
always is perfectly fine for for an
Internet event yeah and maybe a little
bit slow yeah and maybe somehow count
the top 30 scores next time I don't know
if that's complicated to implement or
anything but should we should be well ok
so we're definitely gonna print screen'
this and you know congratulate everyone
once again on Twitter Facebook and of
course all the other social networks so
make sure to congratulate all the teams
and especially our team for sixth place
it's a very good stuff so ok for the end
of the stream we're gonna play a few
games each sure to finish the note beers
yeah the apple juice sparkling yeah
very good duck chess got 55 points for
the team thank you very much gorgeous
that is that is incredibly impressive
really
oh so you're one of these off zero ok oh
it's it's not a large meeting so I guess
yeah alpha zero very nice ok I will
start off the the thing ok with the
casually surprised there aren't more
players named alpha zero it's a pretty
popular one lately
who is the co-host this is my good
friend Sergey Kerrigan how do you say in
Russian bossy bossy one actually this is
embarrassing actually
when did some Russian yeah yeah I went
on a course in rush
I know how to read the Cyrillic but I
totally forgot all flash and no it's
pretty I guess it's pretty similar to
creation how this yeah it is good
afternoon or good evening dobriy vecher
there is a good Russian yeah okay
started playing playing as a user who
just said I will pound keyboard yeah or
maybe my user name
maybe his cat yeah and yeah we're gonna
try to what way as always what would you
say the how difficult it is to become a
grandmaster someone is asking it's very
easy
yeah everyone doing these days you just
play chess and walk in there that's it
oh okay what happens after pawn captures
on e4 interesting so how are we gonna do
this I'm doing what I'm gonna play one
game you one game I think you can play
like three and then I'm gonna play three
in that that's a wrap okay I hope I win
some of them I think I think you're
you're doing well thank you I think I
want a piece but let's wait just a
little bit maybe something will happen
no I don't think there's anything that
can happen here yeah we're gonna discuss
the name and yeah once again good job a
meetin ROG there was a remarkable
performance quite nice yes okay yeah I
forgot to add mods for the stream but I
so rarely stream that I I always forget
to add mods oh yeah we did it for the
last one yeah but yeah okay last one was
a was a big stream this one was a tinier
one but still oh you think like this
it is also a Thursday yeah so maybe less
people joined no I don't think that
that's the thing but it was a four-hour
stream you know last time it we had some
prizes so yeah yeah that's true
okay now it's only our streaming in this
game no you know who knows maybe other
people will stream it watch the phone
okay people are medicine yeah people are
mad at a certain um bar but yeah like I
said sort of sorry about not having a
mod this time definitely something I
will take into account for the next
stream for the next stream I will even
create mods before starting the stream
that way we have everything ready
what really yeah and hopefully the
stream won't crash that's a good move
yes another piece oh you're quite the
collector but he found a nice nice thing
to do there so I didn't win a piece
after all okay yes I mean I won the one
before
ah sorts a kappa blanka is asking when
will there be another tournament of this
type well since we're not the organizers
yeah we aren't the right people but we
can organize it if if if you guys
enjoyed this if you guys liked the team
battle stuff we can do it like more
often
okay I'm going for it
yeah there were so many good suggestions
for the team name I stuck with the
original it's just the one that that was
offered a matter steam so for now we
went with that one trail of says he
contributes five dollars and see he says
please been on board the dude has a
severe okay that's a I was watching the
stream so I didn't I don't see any
amperage yeah me neither actually
so who is this troublemaker I don't know
but he obviously people don't like him
and in the great great stream as well
thank you mister tray alright can you
can you win this hopefully um are you
going for meat or I'm not sure I don't
go Bishop gg6 why is he not resigning he
wants he wants to grab uh really men
I'll definitely that was good yeah try
too much I guess I definitely have to
get a better chair for the stream I will
play a little bit it's not three plus so
because we got too many three plus so
yeah you can go to plus so you can go
bullet you can go so playing against
fake fifteen hundred's okay so you might
be a twenty five hundred
okay I have to play faster this one a
mod is someone that takes care of the
the chat in the stream so if someone is
you know being nasty in the stream or
harassing people then you just ban him
either entirely or you know about him
for like the a few minutes mm I think
you can ban someone for like five
minutes I've never been a mod so I don't
know yeah but you YouTube algorithm has
a has a mod of its own I see a lot of
messages that you guys don't see since
they are not very nice and they are
immediately deleted but some of them are
not obviously okay so mr. fake 1500
gives up a pond yes very nice for now
yes a mod is a moderator how do you
apply for the mod spot well basically I
I pretty much know people who comment on
the videos and you know who follow the
stream so if you apply to be a mod and I
recognize your handle then that's that's
a done deal and if not you know you can
also just apply but no like I said for
the next stream I will try to do it in
advance so we don't have any you know
suspicious ideas here in the industry
chat yeah do you want to give it up you
do yeah you do let's try yeah you do
that Bishop on c3 is not letting any
rooks in the game yeah peace
yeah it's it's shame he had a good run
[Music]
yeah alright one more alright so for
last I'm gonna choose a bullet bullet
okay are there any bullets challenges I
don't think so I think everyone
challenge other there is one Apple Epis
67 another oh you don't have a good
result there so I'm gonna try and nope
are you gonna go for the c3 yes do I
love the London system no but it's
growing on me seeing what Magnus is
doing with it ah I might give it a few
few tries we'll see how it goes
who's your friend is here GM yes he said
via car again he's a very strong
grandmaster yes sir don't mess with me
you will be world champion
[Music]
oh there I this before I think it's
still good the slow mode for the chat I
scream so really I don't even know what
a slow mode is it's like so the the chat
goes slower I guess I guess that's what
it is
she could have played b4 with an attack
on the night and then the g5 Bishop
could have been nice yes when I tried
the Scandinavian it worked
the London system might also work well
okay I will I will try it of course that
Serbia correct you know I would not be
tricking you look look at the moves I'm
making yes come on okay he's killing it
let's be serious
thus we die over there okay I think it's
it's bullet time okay that was that was
unnecessary okay that was good that was
very good
but you are at around master story yeah
so it was expected yes yeah well back to
my mom beer yes and now you have the the
not-so-great chair oh well okay all
right
where do we have it if you okay oh yeah
yeah that's that's what I meant by not
such a such a great chair should've
bought you a new chair for Christmas
yeah okay we are against mr.
indestructible who goes for the
Scandinavian I like it and he goes for
the for the sneaky sneaky pawn sacrifice
but I will not be accepting
so we'll see we'll see what happens
alright ok now I will communicate with
the chat hmm if Kara King was faking the
stutter old do I stutter and no maybe an
interview if she if your yeah he started
stuttered all the time you know in
interviews but you are not starting
enough so I guess you were faking it
before yes that's the only explanation
that was my plan for the World
Championship
yeah match title do like the fake the
stutter to make Magnus feel more
comfortable around me so I can strike I
can see that that sounds like a like a
very good plan yeah it's a proper I saw
c-4 is definitely coming oh no it's not
d4 is d4 is hanging but do we mind that
no we don't actually we don't let's
let's try some ideas like this okay that
I did give a corn but I have two very
good Knights so you know anything could
happen okay so this is hanging this is
an idea you know your games are always
pretty much let's put all the pieces in
front I think that if I roll yes and
since he is deciding on what to do yeah
I guess I thought he was gonna go for f5
but I guess this also works yeah well
okay I mean this is a must
that's like that's like a free game
worth a good point yeah yeah it's like a
completely free game well I don't want
to lock his Queen in the game so I'm
gonna do it like this and now we also
have some action here followed by Queen
h5 since this will be pinned who knows
anything can happen here you had a
donation from someone trail of oh thank
you mister trail off with a nice message
yeah as we are Grandmaster self sarcasm
okay queen of six how do we punish that
it's
it's a good move how would you punish a
good move how would I punish a good move
I guess by by capturing here it has to
be played right of course and then if
you're playing captures captures Queen
check King g7 and then what check here
okay we also have a bishop here oh yeah
that's that's not Oh should I suggest no
no yeah we have to kick away the bishop
the character and then then I guess it
works it's okay
c5 it's even weirder I did not expect c5
okay but this has to be good doesn't
matter doesn't matter we just give up
stuff okay
now this should work we're not even
gonna calculate yeah probably should buy
but you know
okay let's even do this you know it that
just looks very nice so we should most
definitely okay that's what are you
doing good sir
you're like sacrificing everything like
what are you doing it's like I'm
painting something here playing like at
all no that's not what I was going for
yes we will definitely capture that and
bring the other guy into the game I mean
okay I was thinking you will play Queen
86 when the knight was there ah okay
that gives me a lot of ideas actually a
lot like this one here
oh okay
yeah but then queen g4 I get the rook
into the game okay
I know so it's a weird idea but I think
it should work like he doesn't have any
back rank ideas I mean that okay I can
see that happening
Queen g6 is the threat a lot of other
threats as well if Queen g7 then just
Queen h4 or yes looking good yeah yeah
thank you for the game mister
indestructible
although mods for the next one yeah okay
that's Wow thank you mister
indestructible will game it was a weird
game but but a good game alright okay
definitely mods for the next one yeah
definitely mods for the next one thank
you guys for suggesting that okay mr.
Spock let's go but yeah I wanted to ask
how can you choose before the stream if
nobody is in the stream I you actually
can appoint more okay so we were gonna
go for this you can actually appoint
moderators before the stream they are
then moderators for the entire channel I
think not just the stream okay so I'm
gonna go for Bishop d3 here it's a new
new line if people play so you don't
have to go here you can just go here for
some reason it's it's becoming popular
yeah it's a it's a pawn so we'll see how
it goes
[Music]
goodnight mr. mr. harsh [ __ ] yeah I knew
that
Crozier was complaining definitely knew
that okay so it's move with the night
back fine we're just gonna Castle and
decide what to do with the bishop later
I guess haven't really studied anything
in this line other than that the bishop
retreat is also possible here thank you
thank you mr. Spiro for the for the
generous contribution thank you very
much hope to hope to get a game against
you on the on the stream okay so nothing
really happening here still just have to
decide how to develop my pieces yeah I
do have to give him some activity so
yeah still don't know the reason why the
Bishop on d3 is is any better but okay
rook c8 he defends the C pawn here in
case it's needed I guess I can trade now
and get the other night into the game I
guess that's how you unleash the bishop
or no and then play d3 let's go okay now
I can develop like this also
yeah the back of the not-so-good chair
has a crack that's true let's put a
bishop on this nice diagonal I should
also play a bit faster most definitely
yeah okay that's no idea what just
happened here
so I don't even have to capture right
away I can just play a four I guess
so if Bishop age 3 I can block yaki he's
gonna do it like this even better even
better actually did I miss any good news
not from my side no the hood
what is this donation oh that's that's
mr. spiro Oh mr. spiro very nice okay so
we do have to capture now okay
Oh playing against mr. Spock yeah okay
we just capture you know let's just
bring this guy in
make sense keep the tension keep the
tension no we don't keep the tension oh
man oh man he's not gonna capture here I
know he can't okay at least that it's
all good yeah that's the problem with
the bishop on d3 is it just it just has
no point being there
how about Bishop h7 if I try to trick
him like that there's a watch out
there's well Jimmy Jimmy okay page seven
followed by d4 that's what I'm going for
I'm trying to trick him yeah I did
I did get the trick okay what should be
four yeah it's rigged yourself yeah I
did trick myself actually yeah yeah
that's that's a shame
that's a shame Wow how did you manage to
lose I don't know
I'll hold Bishop there okay yeah that's
my my genius Bishop h7 plan yeah it
seems like a good one okay but you still
have your phone up yeah but not really
other than that not really anything else
yeah we cannot trade still something huh
okay yeah that's not not very playable
but I have to trade rooks and push all
the pawns who are you most excited to
see players Tata Steel okay we can take
this opportunity to tell me who is
actually playing because I don't know Oh
everyone everyone everyone explained but
since I'm here I'm not playing yeah okay
I'm gonna be stuttering somewhere else I
guess okay okay there was no need to do
that you're one of these guys who don't
resign yeah but I'm gonna make it tough
with yang will check with check man know
when you get some silly checkmate
okay so I guess we can even maybe get a
draw here no no I wanna I want that was
crazy
alright sorry about that I mean it was I
was completely lost but like I said I I
rarely resign chess is ruthless
all right I'm gonna do a bullet for the
for the end and that's that's it for
this as this is a short stream all right
mr. Chronos Magnus
let's let's do this sir thank you for
the game sir yes good luck mr. Curless
yeah it was all part of the plan okay
we're gonna go for this he knew I was
gonna go for the Scandinavian what a
sneaky dude he saw that video yeah I
don't know he might have okay it's a bit
premature I would say push-up it too and
you should be okay so good stuff good
stuff
mmm careful not no no what the Queen
dude yeah I would but if you could have
kept but okay I will okay that's just
weird whatever he's doing but it's a
bullet game now okay that's a queen Wow
mr. rezaian says the screen gets
overlapped by our faces and we cannot
see the captures please okay resigned aw
man
oh you may here uh I don't know he I
guess he didn't want to oh you mean like
the captures above and the load leeches
stuff what
oh he is complaining that he cannot see
the captures because of our faces so I
think he's thinking of like what is
captured on oh I don't think anyone
watches that mr. zine does oh yeah I
never knew that yeah so okay you want a
queen yeah apparently you're winning
very easily against everybody in this
opening yes that that's true it's it's a
good opening it's not me yeah okay but
that's definitely it for this dream as I
planned it to be shorter stream and they
still have to actually go to Zagreb
today so yeah thank you all for joining
and thank you all for helping us win
sixth place in the in the first ever a
large-scale HS team battle so thanks for
that and yeah don't forget to
congratulate everyone once I publish the
results from our endeavor and you know
that's that's it for this soon thank you
all for coming and thank you and for
once again you're welcome
take note the time from your busy day no
problem thank you joy see you guys